lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
obtener práctica al estimar el producto
de números con varias cifras no hay
manera de obtener práctica si no lo
intentamos nosotros mismos entonces aquí
dice que estimemos 29 x 3.198 porque no
pasa en el vídeo y tratan de estimar el
resultado y por supuesto pueden hacer
esto multiplicando estos números en un
papel o usando calculadora pero sería
útil si lo hacen en la mente traten de
estimar cuál sería el resultado antes de
que revisemos estas respuestas
yo diría que esto es aproximadamente
igual a vamos a ver 29 está muy cerca de
30 y podría multiplicar esto por 3200
que es muy cercano a 3 mil 198 o si
quiero una aproximación más burda diría
que esto es igual a 30 por 3000 si
multiplico 30 por 3 mil 3 por 3 es igual
a 9 y tengo 12 34 012
340 y en realidad mi aproximación está
aquí 90 mil
ahora si quiero una mejor aproximación
podría haber multiplicado 30 por 3200 y
esto también lo pueden hacer en su mente
podrían decir cuánto estrés por 32 bueno
es igual a 96 y tenemos 12 30 12 30 este
resultado sería una mejor aproximación y
si esto es lo que obtuvieron la
respuesta más cercana sigue siendo 90000
hagamos otro ejemplo aquí nos piden
estimar 137 por 18 pausa en el vídeo
nuevamente y traten de estimar el
resultado intenten resolverlo
mentalmente bueno hay varias maneras de
abordar esto la manera en que lo voy a
resolver es diciendo que esto es muy
cercano a 140 por 20 y entonces esto es
igual a 14 por 2 que es 28 y tenemos dos
ceros este resultado podría ser
aproximadamente 2.800 pero cuando busco
la respuesta no está 2800 y la respuesta
más cercana que tenemos aquí es 2
esta podría ser una aproximación otra
manera de hacerlo más burda que parece
que es la que hicieron aquí es redondear
esto a la centena más cercana que es 100
100 x y esto lo redondearon a la decena
más cercana 100 por 20 que inclusive es
más fácil de resolverlo mentalmente es
igual a 2000 y es la opción que tenemos
aquí
terminamos